is Harley Quinn crazy fans have loved
her since she first appeared and Batman
the Animated Series but she remains a
tough character to peg down and both her
adventures in Suicide Squad and with the
birds of prey Margot Robbie's take on
the fan-favorite character is incredibly
complex she's dangerous
she's violent she's sexy she fights
witches with a baseball bat and has a
pet hyena but is she crazy plenty of
versions of Gotham City have played with
the idea of Arkham Asylum but they
mostly focus on what happens when things
go wrong with the patient's not the work
being done by the doctors so we wanted
to talk with someone in the mental
health field to break down what makes
Harley Quinn the cupid of crime and the
made of mischief hi my name is dr. Dre
Ola - Mindy I'm a clinical psychologist
writer for fandom and host of the
podcast the Arkham session crazy is a
complicated word in a way yes it's true
that Harley Quinn is crazy
but in a way she's not so I think in the
common vernacular crazy simply means
someone who is out of control
unpredictable volatile maybe even
violent in terms of the psychological
use of crazy it just isn't a term that
the field uses I would consider the
common word crazy to be applied to
Harley Quinn but there's so much more to
her than that term okay question
answered so what exactly is going on
with Harley how would you describe the
state of Harley Quinn's mental health so
a lot of people associate the word crazy
with somebody who's out of touch with
reality hearing voices or seeing things
that aren't there someone who's
delusional digging a little deeper we
see that even though yes she's a bit
unpredictable she has a propensity for
violence she seems to be pretty grounded
in reality she's not psychotic she does
however use her craziness to kind of
gain control of situations either the
crazy ones so Harley manipulates
people's expectations of her with her
behavior does that mean making people
write her off as crazy is her superpower
what's really great about Harley Quinn
and Suicide Squad is that she seems to
have a pretty strong self-awareness so
she knows that other people interpret
her as psychotic a killer this kind of
wild card and that can scare people what
was that I should kill everyone admits
gay sorry the voices I think that Harley
is actually pretty intuitive knows that
if other people are going to be scared
of her that she can use that to her
advantage
so she'll say she hears voices she'll
say that she's out of control but I
don't think that those things are
actually there I think she's quite
brilliant in her way of understanding
how those things can impact other people
everyone can see was tripping magic
stuff right yeah my meds but if she's
aware and present why actually go
through with the dangerous and violent
actions she takes on a regular basis she
can't just be protecting her reputation
as a Gotham super criminal right what
drives her to act the way she does the
Harlequins role it's just so it's
nothing
no one gives to who we are beyond that
when we look back in her life we see
that she's had multiple traumatic
experiences starting with an abusive
relationship with the Joker
into continued pervasive abuse in the
you know detainment center that she's in
in the beginning of Suicide Squad and we
see some flashbacks that she has of her
experiences there the different ways in
which she was overpowered abused
physically emotionally and maybe even
sexually and a lot of research tells us
that people who are in situations where
they're detained for periods of time and
when they sustained repeated abuse this
way there's long-term psychological
effects people like us we don't get
normalize it always a knife fight every
single time you open your mouth in
Harley's case she's been living like
this for years
what kind of long-term effect does that
have on someone how does Harley deal
with that kind of trauma
you know while she's experiencing a lot
of this traumatic pain and she's kind of
working through all those different
triggers the flashbacks the sensations I
think for Harley she is able to overcome
that pain and find pleasure and joy in
everyday things what a way to start my
new life the perfect egg sandwich the
other thing about her psychology is that
because she's numbed out so much in
order to feel pleasure she dials up some
of the situations that she's in which
would be why she seems so at home in a
place as volatile and violent as Gotham
City for most of us maybe were enjoying
a nice drive on an open freeway or
something that is kind of a common
everyday simple joy
Harley may have numbed out so much that
she has to engage in really high-risk
situations ones that are actually even
dangerous to her in order for her to
feel alive and this is really common for
people who have experienced pervasive
repeated trauma and it can be actually
really dangerous for folks who put
themselves in situations that might harm
them or might put them at risk family
tells me a whole lot of people are about
to die but even with a pattern of
extreme and dangerous behavior that you
think people would want to avoid or
combat there's something alluring about
Harley why do heroes and villains alike
seem so drawn to her Harley is also a
mental health practitioner she was a
psychiatric intern we can see some
elements of her ability to connect with
other people so her emotional
intelligence is actually pretty high she
is really bright and sharp when it comes
to understanding how people's
experiences have impacted their
psychology do you say we and I think
something that people don't give her
enough credit for is her ability to
understand that life is about finding
pleasure and everyday things so to see
her be playful and joyful and make a sad
situation funny I think is her way of
connecting to other humans and actually
is a sign of somebody who's a really
good therapist Harley Quinn nice to meet
you as an audience we root for our
protagonists and heroes we always hope
there's a way forward through their
trauma and pain does Harley actually
have one wanting to notice that Harley
is able to connect with others in a
healthy way and so we see this in
Suicide Squad where she's really fond of
the other members of Task Force X you're
on my friend too she's around other
people that she relates to and that have
similar histories and similar
experiences of being marginalized and
detained and so I think she's found
camaraderie in
around those people and that could be
pretty healthy right yo ass is not
driving I think that's hopeful because
we see that Harley is finding that she
doesn't have to co-mingle abuse and
pleasure or pain and joy that she can
find something a little bit more healthy
from another person out of curiosity we
checked in with Margot Robbie to ask the
actress that had to get into Harley's
head how she sees Harley's mental
illness they could be like elements of a
lot of other illnesses in their little
manic depressant definitely the PTSD
thing loves to analyze people and
someone like the Huntress who has
massive childhood trauma that's just
like that's so exciting to her it's like
oh I want to get in their brain and pick
it apart
she's got rage you know psychologically
speaking vengeance rarely brings the
catharsis we hope for all of these
layers for better or worse is all part
of why fans have related to Harley since
her debut in 1992 she's not just the
Joker's ex she's not just a pair of
short shorts and she's definitely not
just crazy
there's been a long-standing
misconception about Harley Quinn and her
mental state I think that there's this
assumption that she fits that sort of
stereotype of crazy that is just a whole
lot of pretty and a whole lot of crazy
and actually really pleased with Margot
Robbie's representation of her because
we're seeing a lot of layers here and if
we kind of shift our lens there and
think about this woman as a
multi-dimensional person who has
experienced so many setbacks so many
interpersonal abusive traumatic
experiences that then we get her we
understand why she's playful and close
with us and then she can be distant and
even threatening toward us and then we
see that she's actually trying to
overcome that past we're seeing that
she's trying to be you know fully
satisfied and just on her own so with
all the different iterations of this
character I think we can really
transcend this kind of idea of her being
crazy and wherever that journey takes
the character of Harley Quinn next fans
will be right behind her every setback
and every victory
[Music]
you